hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach
I had an error where everything on my
screen just kind of froze all at once so
I got a lost what I had been recording
before but don't worry not much happened
I got a card and I'm down in the nuclear
silos and I turn off the warheads that's
all that happened there were no scares
there was no nothing I also got the ring
and the book I got those two things but
as you will see I've got a friendly
surprise here for everybody
VB 106 1 to jump on my nuts and also I'm
like stuck down here I need to get out
ahh go hey but this stupid are you
friggin barked hi I need to I need to
get out of here I do not want to go into
there so I'm going to get out of here go
straight up or straight down I don't
know I tried this before and it didn't
go anywhere how can he get me who's in
nothingness
I don't even think he can teleport me
when I'm no oh yes he can
Wow he cannot he can indeed he can okay
whatever I guess I'm here now let's just
try to get out of here as fast as
possible actually let's get the burnt
note cuz I definitely do need that at
some point I was gonna have to come in
here eventually can my ring which
protects me from mimetic effects protect
me from here I can't carry anymore cuz
take too much crap
gimme that's not a burnt note oh yeah
that's a burn okay
it just didn't look like a burn yo okay
we're fine just carry on that's what I
get for cheating I swear I get I just
get boned every time I want to cheat and
you know what you guys missed out on a
lot of stuff Oh am I on the swinging
bridge ah I'm on the swinging bridge how
did I get on the bridge was just going
straight bodge that's not fair what
why'd that happen what that happen how
did I go immediately on the swinging
bridge okay what I need to do to get
through this whoa
see I went straight from here maybe Oh
No yeah and then it led straight to the
swinging bridge
I need to wait for one to pass in front
of me so
hello I didn't see it though who those
it okay go go go now we go
as fast as can destroy Tokyo Bay okay oh
my god haha
the other die I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die okay okay okay listen believable I
did it who's know how what you're so
full of [ __ ]
yours Oh beloved it yeah that's the book
I was talking about the encyclopedia of
common diseases I have that now you're
so full of [ __ ] I got through all that
you just kill me why not falling [ __ ] yo
hago wait did I just die does that mean
dying
did I die I died how did that guy you
can't control it I'm not trying to what
is going on Oh
shelter
except what's just happened oh man
is that what's supposed to happen am I
supposed to die in there somehow and
then over and over and over again until
until he decides that I can go all right
so the SCP containment force is here and
they're trying to contain everything
hello
I'm not going that way I gotta find a
way out who's this this is a blocked off
area so I only got let me back let me
backtrack a bit see if I can find if
there's something interesting on the way
back where's my map say I'm my map says
I'm nowhere good for it good for it I'm
still glad that it told me that I also
got the super navigator in the super gas
mask so that's that's nice no I'm here
cool
that means George Maynard six eight to
eight from Maine art six let's see here
we go six eight two eight enter booyah I
don't think there was anything in here
I've been in here once but this is
actually well it's actually kind of nice
because it kind of means and my frame
rates dropping which means the games
gonna crash at any minute
oh that's just saying that this was it
was in an SG Pickett and berries was an
inside job rebel rebel rebel can't carry
anymore douche I don't need batteries
anymore okay mysterious note you made it
easy
nice work Foundation let screw you screw
you up the bot
okay so anyway yep frame rates dropping
I'm gonna crash at any moment here let's
just save ah crap another dead end
this isn't even a specific gate dude
just give me a damn block door damn
block door damn you block door okay I
don't any think I can get into any of
these so just try to remember this area
for later future reference alright was
that it that was it right there was
nothing over here or did I check over
here
another Tesla guy I should put on my
super breathing mask come on haha hey
that was quick
you're trying to get me there they were
trying to get me seriously framerate
settle your chat okay no no no no no
don't go that way that way leads to
death and pain this way leads to I don't
know some nice don't have any ah yeah
seriously prey right settle your [ __ ] I
don't know why it does this like as much
as this game has come along there's
still many bugs to it late their
framerate bugs are crashing bugs or
memory Alain access violations and I
wish I could say with perfectly as I
shut it kind of ruins the experience
after a little bit maybe it has to do
with me recording I don't know maybe it
just doesn't like to be recorded alright
I guess we can go this way
oh hello
it's 682 s containment chamber let's see
let's just sprint through this pretty
quickly cuz I hate going around these
stairs if I could go straight what was
that is that light okay that was just a
light I thought that was like an eye or
something
I'm very weirded out no need to go in
there nothing to see nothing to see
nothing to do I see nothing to do sweet
save awesome making good progress you're
not in there you douche good that
sounded like him ha I saw on the
computer monitor I saw that can't fool
me I'm the junior man what is this oh
[ __ ] oh it's not not you a cop I'm not
gonna how do you get up [ __ ] oh no no
Oh
if it
there's no freaky it was a weird
combination of the two voice acting
going on there
let's see if I can go the other way oh
good it's open now I still don't know
what that does I don't want to go in
here
okay just not looking at your fuel pump
on oh okay I don't know what that does
what is it Dean let me just hang on
get in the on position okay actually it
just returns to the off so it's not
firing it's got to be something don't
look at him looking don't look don't
look don't look at him don't look at him
don't look at him don't look at him haha
I can't even be facing towards him see
generator domain maybe it's got to go to
the generator I'm not sure does it go
main or generator I think it needs to go
the generator hi ah don't kill me
look le I got my Zoomer running back
look at my ring look at my best okay bye
Doug a light Wow Doug la sorry
this is stupid why was he right there
never access violation I knew it was
coming I knew it was coming
oh my god the sub dumped him so much
it's just uh I can't believe I ran away
from him for that long
okay fraction three two one oh ah ah hey
he haunts my nightmares if there was any
any any monster any video game that ever
gave me an idea it would be him just
just a thought like you're sitting in
bed when you go to bed tonight just
imagine you're sitting you're in bed and
you got your eyes closed so you're nice
and safe but he's in the room like he's
just standing in the corner just not
doing anything he's just standing there
and if you open your eyes even for a
second you will see him like he's
hovering like as you go drift off to
sleep he's hovering like right here if
you open your eyes for even a moment you
kill you so he dreams everybody have a
nice night okay where am I now
oh I'm staring right into the room I
don't want to Peter never access
violation what a [ __ ] stop never pay
access violation until I go okay Barker
bar you've had enough of this just calm
down
go go go sleep go go take a nap all
right
perhaps in three two one OOP uh like I
said before this game is nice but it
would really be great if they worked out
the bugs because there are considerable
number of bugs I'll be one of the
scariest games ever made but at the same
time I gotta get their [ __ ] together I'm
just kidding I'm just joshing it
technically is still not even in
released yet it's still like in beta cuz
its point oh it's zero point seven point
one it's not one they have not released
1.0 yet and I'm surprised they haven't
charge money for this because house a
lot of game here you know I mean when it
first started out who's really simple at
the same time but I mean so is SCP uh
one or memory access violation okay the
game sincerely does not want me to play
right now I will try to get back to it
soon but
we've been playing for a while now so
anyway I'll work out the kinks later
I'll get that all settled it probably
just like I need to restart my computer
or something I have no idea it doesn't
like me recording at the same time so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching I hope you have a good night's
sleep today just remembering on 9:6
right there don't look at him so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that i've
done and as always I will see you in the
next
ah
Oh
what I'm seeing so far